what i hope to do in this video is a
reasonably quick justification of the
idea that the absolute value of a minus
b
is equal to the absolute value of b
minus a
for any two numbers a or b
and though before i even break into this
i want to start with a simpler
proposition
the idea that if i have some number x
that the absolute value and i'm just
using x since i already used up a and b
that the absolute value of x is going to
be the same thing as the absolute value
of negative x
and to feel good about this we could
draw a number line
so
we could draw
a number line
and
this is zero so there's one
circumstances which in which x is
positive obviously if x was zero then
these are both going to be equal to zero
and it would be true but one world where
x is positive then negative x would be
the same distance to the left of zero
so negative x would be here
and the absolute value of x would be
this distance
and the absolute value of negative x
would be that same distance but just 2
just to the left so these two things
would be equivalent
now if x were negative so let me draw
that
so
if x were negative so if this was x then
what would negative x be
well negative x would be the opposite of
it so it would be the same distance to
the right of zero so i know this looks
weird me putting the negative x out here
but remember x could be negative two and
if x is negative two then negative
negative two is going to be positive
but either way you see that the absolute
value of these two things are the same
the absolute value is just the distance
from zero this distance
is still going to be the same as this
distance this distance is the absolute
value of x this distance in this case is
the absolute value of negative x so
hopefully you feel good that these two
things that these two things are
equivalent
now if you agree to that now let's work
on
now let's work on this a little bit
so
we can
we can start with the absolute value of
a
minus b
and there's a bunch of there's a bunch
of ways that we could we could tackle
this but one way we could do we can we
can we can approach it is and actually
let me write a little lower so i don't
bump into this stuff right over here
so let me start with the absolute value
of a minus b
now a
we could rewrite this is a positive or
this is just a i don't want to say it's
positive or negative a a could be a
negative number but this is just a right
over here but we can rewrite this as
being the same thing as negative
negative a
or i guess negative negative a
plus
or let me write this minus b
minus b so let's just take a let's just
take a let's just think about this a
little bit and make sure we feel
comfortable with what i just with what i
just did
so
this a
this a is the same thing as all of this
business the negative
negative a the negative of a negative is
going to be a positive this is positive
a so i haven't changed this in any in
any dramatic way
but what's this going to be the same
thing as
well we can factor out a negative sign
so let's do that and actually let me we
could factor out
just in a color that i haven't used yet
we could factor out
the negative signs
so this is going to be equal to
the absolute value of i can factor out
the negatives
the negative of
and then i have open parentheses
open parentheses negative a and if you
factor out a negative here this is going
to be positive b
so or plus b plus b
let me just close the parentheses in the
same color just to make the match
now why is this interesting
well we just said the absolute value of
a negative is the same thing as the
absolute if the absolute value of
negative x is the same thing as the
absolute value of x
so the absolute value of the negative of
negative a plus b is going to be equal
to
this is going to be equal to
the absolute value let me do that yellow
color
it's going to be equal to the absolute
value of this thing without the negative
written here you see that right over
here the absolute value of negative x is
the same thing as the absolute value of
x so the absolute value of negative
negative a plus b is the same thing as
the absolute value of
negative a
plus b
negative a plus b
plus b
and negative a plus b well that's the
same thing as b
minus a
i'm just swapping the order right over
here b
minus
b
minus a
and we're done we've just shown that the
absolute value of a minus b is the same
thing as the absolute value of b
minus a and obviously hopefully you
already felt pretty good about it by
just trying out a bunch of numbers and
thinking about the number line and
thinking about what the difference of
two numbers mean if one is larger than
the other but this is we're just
literally just really uh factoring out a
negative sign here and recognizing this
property up here to make the same
conclusion